[Musique]
bonsoir très heureux de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv 78 nous
sommes le lundi 15 mars voici les titres
de ce journal en pleine crise sanitaire
l'hôpital privé de versailles se dote de
nouvelles urgences les travaux du
service qui accueille 25 mille passages
chaque année ont été menées lors du
deuxième confinement reportage et
d'après un dernier baromètre 60% des
français ont déjà réalisé des travaux de
rénovation énergétique de plus en plus
de personnes s'y met avec des aides
possibles comme ma prime rénove ouverte
depuis cette année également
copropriétaire invités de cette édition
raphaël gère son directeur régional
adjoint de la dame ile-de-france et puis
transports d'ici 2022 quarante deux
dépôts de bus dans la région seront
transformés objectif leur permettre de
recharger les véhicules en électrique ou
en biométhane samedi la présidente de la
région valérie pécresse était venu
inaugurer la mutation du site
à conflans sainte honorine présentation
également tout à l'heure du deuxième
challenge crypto challenge qui est une
initiative lancée par un guyancourt toi
c'est à l'occasion de la semaine des
maths
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ces titres la
campagne de vaccination déjà stoppé
momentanément pharmacie elle avait
débuté aujourd'hui les professionnels
des officines pouvait injecter le vaccin
astrazeneca
mais l'utilisation de ce dernier a été
temporairement interdite en france
annonce aujourd'hui du président de la
république emmanuel macron c'est
effectif pendant au moins 24 heures et
ce par précaution en attente d'une
décision de l'agencé européenne du
médicament est la campagne de
vaccination qui s'accélérait depuis
quelques jours comme pour les 6 et 7
mars
les centres de vaccination sont restés
ouverts le week end dernier vingt-cinq
mille doses pfizer ont été alloués pour
ces deux jours d'opérations en
ile-de-france au total dans les yvelines
plus de 86 mille personnes ont été
primés vacciner environ 4000 doivent
recevoir une seconde injection dès cette
semaine une situation presque hors de
contrôle en ile de france les mots du
directeur de crise de l'ap-hp à propos
de l'épidémie regarder ces derniers
chiffres collectés sur une semaine les
lits de réanimation franciliens sont
désormais occupés casier à 100% dans la
région si bien que trois premiers
patients ont été transportés dans des
hôpitaux de province et que l'hypothèse
d'un reconfirme ans est toujours
présente au niveau des chiffres de
l'épidémie les données restent élevés
notamment le taux d'incidence à 302 et
dans les yvelines c'est le nombre de
nouveaux contaminée pour 100000
habitants 506 patients étaient
hospitalisés hier dimanche sur le
territoire et depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire est 1439 personnes sont
entendues colite 19 dans les hôpitaux
yvelinois repenser l'accueil des
patients pour leur confidentialité de
leurs soins l'hôpital privé de
versailles à repenser ses urgences est
des travaux ont été réalisés durant le
2ème confinement ce service recense plus
de 25000 passage chaque année les
précisions de mélanie poquet des
changements dès l'accueil aux urgences
de l'hôpital privé de versailles le
service administratif vous reçoit de
manière sécurisée au deuxième
confinement le service des urgences
s'est refait une beauté
une réorganisation du parcours a changé
pour le personnel soignant a pas de
travail
un qui fait qu'une plus grande fluidité
aussi des informations du travail et à
faciliter ainsi le travail de chacun
avec ses travaux les urgences se voit
doté de deux boxes supplémentaires est
accueillie avec plus d'intimité et de
confidentialité des patients en
hospitalisation très courte durée avec
trois chambres dont une double
téléconsultation été les expertises sont
aussi possibles
quand on a des certains cas par exemple
des de la neuro chirurgie cérébrale
on appelle la grande gare de
neurochirurgie transmet les images et la
même façon et grand garden ou richir
peut voir le patient l'examiner avec des
hommes importants et et donner un avis
il voit si j'ai besoin de prendre le
patient à l'oreille plutôt que de le
transférer ces travaux représentent un
investissement de plus de 450 milles
euros
les urgences de l'hôpital privé de
versailles accueille 25 mille 500
passages par an cette plateforme est né
pour répondre aux problématiques de la
crise sanitaire l'association
entrepreneurs artisans territoire qui
regroupe des professionnels des métiers
de bouche et vient de lancer son service
service de réservation d'hôtels et de
restaurants il est sans intermédiaire et
donc sans commission à la tête de
l'association laurent trochain chef une
étoile et du restaurant numéro trois au
tremblay sur mauldre on les couteaux
micro d'eléonore sinoquet
[Musique]
10 13 à la base c'est une association
pour se retrouver pour parler évidemment
nos problématiques d'entrepreneurs
l'idée vraiment de ce site c'est de
référencer les établissements et qui
mettent leurs liens directs vers leurs
outils de 2,2 de réservation est comme
ça le client est directement en lien
avec eux le but c'est vraiment que le
client soit en lien direct avec le
professionnel c'est à dire qu'il n'y ait
pas d'intermédiaire on remarque bien
trop souvent qu'on a toujours plus ou
moins des intermédiaires lors de
différentes réservation on a le
savoir-faire nous en tant que
professionnel maintenant il faut le
faire savoir aux clients de passer paris
tresa pour être au plus proche de toutes
les maisons des restaurants et des
hôtels de france est très simple c'est à
dire que vous vous choisissez soit une
localisation soit un établissement que
vous connaissez soit une région voilà
c'est au hasard et ensuite vous allez
sélectionnés si vous recherchez une
table à réserver donc en ce moment c'est
pas possible un hôtel lui c'est possible
à mes chambres peuvent être réservés
mais surtout aussi la vente en porte et
vous allez choisir votre habit cement
vous allez cliquer sur vente à emporter
et vous allez tomber directement sur le
module de de réservation ventre portés
de l'établissement plus de 100
établissements sont déjà inscrits depuis
l'ouverture de la plateforme début
février dont environ 15% dans les
yvelines est dans l'actualité cette
agression dimanche soir à chatou le père
du footballeur marquinhos qui évolue au
paris saint germain a été frappé et volé
à son domicile par deux individus
l'homme de 52 ans est également
séquestré avec ses deux filles pendant
que les cambrioleurs lui dérober des
objets de luxe et la somme de 2000 euros
en liquide avant de prendre la fuite
et d'après une source proche du dossier
les malfaiteurs pensait cambrioler la
maison du footballeur qui jouait au même
moment avec son club face à nantes
l enquête a été confiée à la police
judiciaire de versailles dont la même
soirée en réel di maria a été également
cambriolé à son domicile dans le 92 à
mantes-la-jolie un mineur de 17 ans mis
en examen pour association de
malfaiteurs terroristes criminels le
tribunal judiciaire de paris lui a
signifié à sa mise en examen après trois
jours de garde à vue
le jeune avait été interpellé à son
domicile yvelinois mercredi dernier via
la messagerie télégramme l'adolescent
évoqué son intention de s'en prendre à
des militaires il a été placé en
détention provisoire à partir de 2028 il
ne sera plus possible de louer des
logements trop énergivores dits de
catégorie f ou g pour inciter les
propriétaires à faire des travaux est
l'état aide au financement depuis le 1er
janvier 2021 à ma prime ma prime rénove
copro permet aux copropriétaires de
déposer un dossier ensemble la ministre
est déléguée au logement emmanuelle
wargon était à saint germain en laye à
ce sujet vendredi pour signer avec des
professionnels de l'immobilier un
protocole permettant l'accélération des
réservations
astrid berges heures et nicolas landry
des travaux de rénovation énergétique à
la résidence pereire à saint germain en
laye un projet lancé il ya dix ans
objectif permettre à ce bâtiment des
années 60 de respecter les normes
environnementales changement climatique
a accéléré si vous voulez la vétusté du
bâti en kf a entraîné un certain nombre
de pathologies de l'écouté cuisine
chambre ou salle de bains dans bon
nombre d'appartements deviennent de plus
en plus humide
certaines voix par autres de la
moisissure
les copropriétaires ont réussi à se
mettre d'accord sur le projet coût total
des opérations un million sept cent
mille euros
face à ce type de rénovation le
gouvernement a lancé le 1er janvier ma
prime rénove copro et une aide à la
copropriété
alors que jusqu'à présent on aidait en
fonction des situations particulières
chaque copropriétaire ce qui était
beaucoup plus long là la copropriété
fait un seul dossier
on a déjà plusieurs centaines de
dossiers déposés donc ça veut dire que
c'est encourageant
emmanuelle wargon étaient sur place pour
visiter le chantier elle en a profité
pour signer un protocole avec des
professionnels de l'immobilier le but
accélérer la rénovation énergétique en
accompagnant 50000 projet sur trois ans
et cette urgence elle est aussi
dépendante d'une loi qui au 1er janvier
2000 28 interdit les locations f et g
c'est court cette période là nous nous
prenons un engagement sur trois ans
d'initier cette rénovation il y aurait
près des 5 millions de logements
qu'elles
de passoires thermiques donc classé f et
g en france la fin des travaux de la
résidence pereire elle est prévue dans
dix mois et on parle de la rénovation
énergétique avec mon invitant
visioconférence raphaël gère son bon
soir comment vous êtes le directeur
régional adjoint de la dame
ile-de-france lagence de la transition
écologique sur cette thématique
justement de la rénovation énergétique
des bâtiments l'ademe et est engagée
quel est votre rôle à ce sujet alors le
rôle de la laine sur l'ensemble du
territoire et d'accompagner ce qu'on
appelle le programme par vive
d'accompagnement pour la rénovation
énergétique
en fait c'est un service qui vise à
accompagner toutes les structures qui l
ont conseillé directement les
propriétaires les ménages
les copropriétaires les syndics le petit
tertiaire pour les accompagner dans la
transition énergie donc beaucoup
d'acteurs et on va faire un focus tout à
l'heure sur les particuliers justement
quels sont les enjeux à mener cette
thématique de la rénovation énergétique
en ile de france
l'enjeu il est double il est climatique
et il est économique
comme vous l'avait dit dans le reportage
précédent le nombre de passoires
thermiques comme on dit vulgairement
c'est à dire les étiquettes énergétiques
a fait j'ai sont considérables en france
inclus plus de 4 millions de passoires
thermiques
on se concentre sur l'ile-de-france
avait six logements sur 10 qui sont
considérés comme énergivores et c'est à
dire des étiquettes à partir de feu f et
g et logements énergivores
ça se fait au détriment des habitants
puisqu'ils ont des factures énergétiques
élevés donc c'est l'enjeu économique
dont je parle et ses logements
énergivores sont également au
d'une augmentation des gaz à effet de
serre dont george v il est également qui
m'a dit les objectifs en la matière pour
la dame ile de france quels sont ils
chaque année alors le plan de rénovation
énergétique en ile de france
il vise la rénovation de 125 mille
logements
donc c'est effectivement quelque chose
de très ambitieux et c'est pour ça que
l'ademe via ce programme sport soutient
les agences locales énergie climat par
exemple dans le cas des yvelines
la led l' agence locale énergie climat
de saint quentin en yvelines où
également énergie solidaire qui eux ont
déconstruit t on pouvoir conseiller via
la plate mans plateforme faire
directement via les portugais dans ces
structures
on pourra accompagner les ménages les
professionnels et dans les travaux de
rénovation énergétique
on va en parler dans un instant vous le
dirai non non vous le disiez donc vous
accompagnez différents acteurs en ile de
france et est aussi dans la france
entière alors pour le coup c'est les
collectivités territoriales c'est aussi
bien les entreprises et les particuliers
justement pour les particuliers 14% des
français qui ont été interrogés par un
dernier baromètre opinionway estiment
que leur logement est une passoire
énergétique vous parliez vous parliez
tout à l'heure des bonnes raisons de
rénover quand on est un particulier les
bonnes raisons sont multiples on parlait
d'un enjeu environnemental forcément sur
aussi dans l'idée de faire baisser sa
facture il ya un enjeu aussi de sécurité
peut-être il ya plusieurs choses qui
s'entremêlent dans les bonnes raisons
pour rénover son logement
vous avez très bien résumé la chose à la
fois les enjeux de sécurité des anges et
de confort
un des enjeux économiques pour réduire
sa facture
et puis des enjeux de s'engager dans la
transition écologique avec en habitant
un branchement qui met moins de de gaz à
effet de serre et pour ça que l'ademe
via ce programme
il est mis en place par l'état et opéré
par l'ademe accompagne donc cette
transition écologique menée à les
travaux de rénovation énergétique avec
des aides conséquentes via ma prime
rénove m'a pris vraiment qu'aux pros
puisque c'était le cas de notre
reportage précédent lorsqu'on est une
co-propriété une demande des acteurs
donc maintenant les syndics de
copropriétés peuvent mettre en place des
programmes qui vont bénéficier à un
immeuble entier ce qui reviendra au
final moins cher que si chaque voyage à
logements en s et ses travaux
individuellement et avec un impact
or l'ensemble de leurs énormes
vous avez parlé des aides et notamment
de ma prime rénove avec un site internet
qui disent qu'on va peut-être voir
s'afficher ou les très simple de faire
une simulation pour voir de combien on
peut bénéficier pour pour ces aides il
ya forcément six mille questions autour
de cette rénovation énergétique beaucoup
de types de travaux qui existe et vous
parliez tout à l'heure de la possibilité
de se faire accompagner par par des
conseillers a dit faire il ya des
espaces fer qui propose aux particuliers
des conseils personnalisés notamment un
portail internet qu'on pourra voir aussi
s'afficher dans quelques instants avec
finalement à toutes les informations
clés en main pour mener à bien ses
projets de rénovation c'est exactement
ça reflète notre programme il y a trois
choses qui vise à assurer effectivement
cette mission de conseil via les
conseillers faire que vous avez
mentionné qui donne à la fois un conseil
neutre
gratuit indépendant sur sur le plan
technique
sur le plan juridique sur le plan
financier pour identifier les aides
disponibles et monter un plan de
financement global du projet c'est la
première chose qu'on souhaite
la deuxième chose qu'on fait c'est qu'on
va accompagner des années les
particuliers et des professionnels
les conservateurs vont les accompagner
ils vont être leurs référents à chaque
étape
identification des solutions dlp jusqu'à
la phase de contrôle
travaux et enfin la troisième chose
qu'on fait c'est la mobilisation des
acteurs non seulement par les
professionnels du bâtiment qui vont
réaliser les travaux
mais également par tout l'écosystème
c'est à dire les agences immobilières
les études notariales et les grandes
surfaces de bricolage donc tout ours cat
écosystèmes est nécessaire pour
atteindre l'objectif ambitieux de
rénovation énergique une dernière
session qui revient souvent j'imagine le
coût des travaux de rénovation
énergétique
j'allais dire ça dépend de ce qu'il ya à
faire aussi en terme de travaux mais tel
est le budget moyen pour pour mener à
bien ces travaux
alors là ça va vraiment dépendre de tous
les actes que vous voulez faire parce
que on va identifier des actes
d'isolation alors est ce qui est ce que
vous êtes au niveau d'un logement ou
est-ce que vous êtes au niveau d'un
immeuble global on va y voyait
identifier des actes au niveau du
remplacement du système de chauffage qui
va également varier de façon très
conséquente si vous êtes dans une maison
si vous êtes dans un logement beaucoup
plus un immeuble par exemple donc voilà
c'est très difficile de vous donner un
chiffre
par contre ce que ce que vous dire c'est
que si vous allez effectivement comme
vous l'avez dit reçues sur faire point
fr ou sur l'ensemble des plaquettes que
la dlv à votre disposition vous pouvez
avoir une idée plus précise en fonds
propres votre situation
non seulement du des travaux mais
également des aides auxquelles vous
aurez droit qui peuvent être très
conséquente qui peuvent être supérieurs
à 50% en fonction des travaux d'aller à
engager légal énergétique cela va
produire et également de vos revenus
donc il faut faire des simulations et
c'est pour ça que les conseillers faire
vraiment à votre disposition pour vous
accompagner et la campagne sur les
copropriétés qui a lieu en ce moment
elle a dû en ce moment parce que c'est
aujourd'hui en ce moment que les les ag
et par niveau des syndics de copropriété
et donc c'était maintenant qu'il est
alors dite des âges et les travaux vont
en bénéficier des aides très conséquente
qui sont à disposition des ménages en ce
moment sur la rénovation énergétique
avec les différents sites internet qui
se sont affichées durant l'entretien lui
aussi je le précise le site de l'ademe
ile de france et vous l'avez dit on y
retrouve notamment un des plaquettes
autour de cette thématique de la
rénovation énergétique merci raphaël
gerson d'avoir été avec nous c'est un
directeur régional adjoint de l'ademe
ile-de-france qui est l'agent sein de la
transition écologique environnement
toujours mais au rayon des transports
valérie pécresse président
d'ile-de-france mobilité s'est rendu
samedi au dépôt de bus transdev de
conflans sainte honorine
au programme de cette visite
inauguration de la transformation du
dépôt de bus au biométhane le reportage
de justin brasier de patrick jacques de
dixmude à proposer des moyens de
transport modernes et écologiques
voilà la mission que s'est donnée le
syndicat des transports ile-de-france
mobilité samedi 13 mars valérie pécresse
a annoncé l'achat de 1000 nouveaux bus
propres pour la région d'ici 2022 2023
pour pouvoir recharger ces bus en
électrique ou en biométhane pendant la
nuit
40 de dépôt devrait être transformée
d'ici 2022
nous nous sommes mis résolument dans
l'électrique pur j'allais dire les
villes les grandes villes les dessertes
aux courtes distances et dans le gaz le
gnv le gaz naturel de ville pour les
grandes distances ce gaz il peut être
propre ou pas plus ou moins propre mais
il est zéro carbone zéro émission autre
innovation présentée samedi au dépôt de
bus transdev de conflans sainte honorine
un nouveau système de rétrovision il
devrait permettre aux chauffeurs de bus
d'avoir une meilleure vision latérale et
d'éviter les phénomènes d'angle mans en
plus des rétroviseurs physique on ajoute
des caméras qui permettent de compléter
la vision que va avoir le chauffeur de
son environ
et de lui donner de permettre d'abord à
la fois pour les manoeuvres d'être plus
précis mais également ça lui permet
d'avoir une vision sur les parties
latérales du bus qui sont souvent cachés
et d'éviter les accidents
d'ici 2025 plus aucun bus disent elles
ne devraient être en circulation dans la
région ile de france
objectif adapter à terme la totalité des
centres avec de l'électricité ou du
biométhane une fois n'est pas coutume
parlons mathématiques à présent dans ce
journal la deuxième édition du crypto
challenge est lancé par un guyancourt
toi c'est à l'occasion de la semaine des
maths ce concours de codes secrets sur
internet est organisée par un professeur
de mathématiques de
saint-germain-en-laye son interview
express collectées par michael et demi
d'euros alors le crypto challenge c'est
un jeu qui démarre à l'occasion de la
fête des mathématiques du 15 au 22 mars
et qui va durer deux mois l'idée c'est
qu'il ya des textes qui sont cryptés qui
sont codées et on se place dans la peau
d'un hacker un espion ce qu'on veut et
on doit trouver ce qu'il ya derrière le
texte sans avoir de mots de passe
l'objectif c'est de
ben de jouer avec les mathématiques de
jouer avec les langues vivantes de se
casser un peu la tête et voilà c'est de
s'amuser
[Musique]
pour participer il suffit de créer un
compte sur le site
on va choisir un texte on va choisir la
langue et le niveau qu'on souhaite
et puis après si on a réussi à le
décrypter ben c'est comme si on avait
mis un bulletin pour faire un tirage au
sort et le mi mai il y aura un tirage au
sort dans mon collège et les personnes
qui ont
ont été tirés au sort gagneront 1 un
trophée qui sera fabriquée aux fab lab
de la verrière et à la six niveaux
différents
c'est à dire que le niveau 1 c'est du
niveau très facile qui sont accessibles
dès l'école primaire
tous les textes commence par salut je
m'appelle et ça va jusqu'au niveau 6
houla faut vraiment être tenace bien
aimé les énigmes et les textes sont
quand même plus compliqué c'est vraiment
ouvert à tout public
c'est à dire que le principe du site
c'est que c'est les autant les enfants
que les adultes qui peuvent participer
il ya des dispositifs qui sont un peu
particulier sur le site s'il ya des
professeurs qui veulent faire l'activité
en classe entière mais c'est vraiment
ouvert à tout le monde
et sachant que les textes sont
évidemment français mais aussi dans des
langues étrangères
donc par exemple si on est en train
d'apprendre l'anglais et qu'on veut se
tester ben on peut le faire on sur
michael et demi d'euros bonsoir il faut
assurer vous je ne vais pas vous poser
des questions à propos des mathématiques
d'importants j'adore les problèmes bon
on évitera aujourd'hui mais dans
quelques minutes on vous retrouve aux
manettes de votre émission le cetud
sport quel est le programme du soir
le programme parlera rugby à la
fédération française à l'issue de son
bureau fédéral a annoncé l'arrêt des
saisons amateurs 2020 2021 en raison de
la situation sanitaire en france est un
calendrier impossible à tenir le
recevront dans mon émission
les clubs de versailles et de plaisir on
parlera golf également antoine or other
je sais pas si vous connaissez à grégory
lefort à golfeurs effectivement un
golfeur évinois qui vient de la bouillie
a remporté un magnifique trophée c'était
au qatar c'était ce week-end avec un
putt de 20 mètres on en parlera dans
cette émission on parlera également golf
avec le nouveau président de la
fédération française pascal grizot qui
sera avec nous du coup dans cette
émission nous parlerons notamment de
l'open de france de golf et des jo de
enfin on parlera automobile coup de
projecteur sur un binôme yvelinois qui
participera à rallye à 100% féminin et
100% électrique
le binôme s'appelle juliette et axel
watts elle
voilà c'est de l'anb équipe merci
michael on vous retrouve dans un instant
aux manettes du cetud pour sur tv 60,18
voilà c'est la fin de ce genre
merci de votre fidélité rendez vous dès
demain mardi pour une nouvelle édition
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]